when senator kamala harris officially
accepts the democratic party's
nomination to be vice president
she will become just the third woman in
american history on a
major party's presidential ticket the we
have her back campaign is working to
fight any misogyny the senator might
face
it's a group initiative led by
representatives of
super majority emily's list and time's
up now
super majority co-founder and former
planned parenthood president
cecile richards spoke to cbs news
special correspondent
alex wagner for the sunday's episode
of the circus mondale was behind when
ferraro became his running mate sarah
palin
again was seen kind of as a hail mary
pass this time's different joe biden's
ahead right a lot of people say i don't
know this is a high risk
situation i feel just the opposite i
feel like the
excitement and energy among women in
general
is of course off the charts women are
now they've dominated the primaries
this election cycle historic number of
women running for office
the energy that i'm feeling out there in
the countryside
that we would now have the chance to
elect a woman
and have a government that begins to
look like us i think it's going to
energize all voters
the circus airs on show time which is a
division of viacom cbs and we welcome
alex
this morning thanks for joining us
always great to see you michelle great
seeing you even with
an historic number of women running in
the democratic presidential
primary a man is still at the top of the
ticket so what does that
signal about the views of women
candidates
well look it is true that none of those
very
qualified women made it to the top of
the democratic ticket but the
the reality is when you look at voting
patterns when you look at what happened
in the 2018 midterms when america sent
a record number of women to congress you
look at the excitement and the
enthusiasm and the organization of women
in the four years since president trump
was elected
where we seem to be michelle in a
different moment and then if you look at
the polling nationally
there is a chasm that has opened up
between the two candidates women are
breaking for biden by up to 20 points
and that was
before he announced kamala harris as his
running mate
now if you look at early opinion polling
from this week it
seems like his choice of kamala harris
has the approval
of a majority of the country 60 of
americans approve
of his choice of kamala harris including
and this is the important part 37
percent of republicans
so you know the jury is still out but i
would say the trend lines towards
americans embracing a woman in a
leadership role
it seems to be going in that direction
well senator harris has
spoken a lot about our personal story
her family life as a child of immigrants
and her role as
mamala as she likes to turn herself to
her step kids what
what kind of impact does this have
so look i think we're still writing the
book
on what it means to be a woman in power
the mamala story that you heard when the
president the vice president
uh came and introduced uh his running
mate to the country
earlier this week that mama story is
something that anybody on the campaign
trail heard
kamala harris herself tell in the fall
but it doesn't mean that it wasn't a
very deliberate move on the part of the
biden campaign
to try and show kamala harris as a
multi-faceted candidate this is someone
who's a tenacious litigator but she's
also someone who's cooking
a sunday meal she's someone who's at all
the swim meets
and i think that's indicative of the
fact that we want to see women
as people i mean fairly or unfairly who
can do many different things at once
they can be
killer professionals but they're also
great on the domestic front
i'll tell you michelle i was with cory
booker one of kamala harris's besties
yesterday and he's
he spent time telling me the story about
how he was
he the bachelor was trying to cook a pot
of lentils and he called his friend
kamala harris
and she she said you know what corey
let's facetime and she spent time with
him
on the phone guiding him through her
favorite lentil recipe
and teaching him how to chop an onion i
promise you michelle we are going to
hear that onion chopping story
a lot between now and november yeah he's
an easy student
i i i don't understand whether or not he
can cook
but yeah easy student there well
president trump has already been
on the attack called holly harris nasty
a term he only seems to be using
for women he also tweeted that uh he
would
uh get support from the suburban
housewife crew
what is his strategy here
look i think trump in a lot of ways is
running the 2016 playbook he's using a
lot of the same rhetoric he's going for
the sharp
sort of jugular attacks i think it's a
question about whether it's going to
work
i interviewed cecile richards the woman
we heard from earlier in this tape
because she is working preemptively with
a group
of other women who have are all seasoned
political veterans they all head
some of the biggest women's groups in
the country and they're saying we are
preemptively going to issue notice to
media
to the public to candidates we see you
and we are monitoring the ways in which
you are talking about women and we are
developing a war room on our side to
push back against what we see as
misogyny and sexism it's
sort of born out of ptsd of the 2016
race and races thereafter
where they see women as not getting a
fair shake what i think you're seeing
now is an expectation
on the part of women and men to some
degree that things are could get ugly
in terms of gender in this election but
the the sort of
operation the behind the scenes war room
is much more fired up and much more
prepared than they were four years ago
so it'll be interesting to see
how well these attacks on the part of
trump and his allies land
i have seen it in action and they are
calling on their male
allies in particular alex wagner thank
you so much
well the newest season of the circus
returns this sunday on showtime at 8
7 central with the stories behind the
political headlines and we'll
have full coverage of the democratic
national convention right here
on cbs this morning our prime time
coverage begins monday at 10 pm eastern
and